[Music]  tatum  [Music]  backing his way down in one  jason tatum showing you the muscle to  the fade away  take a look on the spin oh that's a  sweet move  [Applause]  save though by williams  tatum there's a step back  is really carrying the celtics right now  on the offensive end  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  three on the clock when tatum goes  baseline  is living at the front of the rim  [Applause]  tatum takes it makes it  on fire keep giving him the ball  [Music]  [Applause]  nice shot by tatum excellent holding off  the defenders  tatum again again  bottom of the net one three  oh my goodness mike  tatum  [Music]  [Applause]  hate him going through the back door